[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 sur TV
78 dans l'actualité de ce lundi 18
septembre Jamel Debbouze de retour dans
sa ville d'origine l'humoriste était à
trap hier à l'occasion du gala caritatif
en soutien au Maroc après le puissant
séisme qui a frappé le pays sont Jamel
Comedy Club était aux côtés de la
municipalité du Secours populaire pour
cet événement de solidarité 7000 euros
ont ainsi pu être récoltés le ministre
de l'éducation nationale Gabriel Attal a
annoncé le lancement d'un audit dans
tous les rectorats de France sur les cas
de harcèlement scolaire cela fait suite
à la révélation d'un courrier envoyé en
mai dernier par l'académie de Versailles
aux parents de Nicolas victime de
harcèlement dans son lycée de Poissy
l'adolescence est suicidé début
septembre une affaire qui vaut de
nouvelles critiques au rectorat de
Versailles déjà dans le viseur après la
gestion du cas Samuel Paty en 20
explications l'actualité sportive dans
les Yvelines avec de bonnes et de
mauvaises nouvelles les Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ne sont pas
champion de France de baseball les inhy
montants se sont inclinés en finale de
Division 1 contre Montpellier mais on
parlera au football de la première
victoire de la saison de Versailles en
National focus également sur les
résultats du troisième tour de la Coupe
de France de football et puis l'invité
du 7 8 en deuxième partie d'émission
avec Jean-Baptiste amonique Le Maire de
Villepreux a été récemment missionné par
le gouvernement et la copiloté l'un des
groupes de travail préparatoires à la
future loi de programmation sur
l'énergie et le climat les lune nous
livrent ces conclusions après 4 mois
intensifs de travail
Jamel s'il te plaît viens viens nous
rejoindre
c'est la surprise Jamel Debbouze a fait
le déplacement pour ce gala caritatif en
soutien au Maroc après le séisme
meurtrier l'humoriste originaire de
Trappes n'a pas fait que rassembler les
artistes du Jamel Comedy Club ce
prétexte était important je rentre du
Maroc et on a conscience des besoins on
connaît bien la communauté marocaine et
pas seulement à trappe et c'est pas il y
avait pas que des Marocains aujourd'hui
heureusement mais on savait que si on
envoyait ce signal il allait avoir un
écho ça le plein est survolté les 800
places de la Meurisse se sont vendus en
moins d'une soirée pour soutenir la
population marocaine et puis chacun
participe comme il peut et là voilà
montrer qu'on est tous solidaires faut
toujours faire un petit peu pour la
population ben comme vous voyez moi
c'est le drapeau du Maroc parce que ben
je viens de là-bas donc il faut aider
quoi on savait qu'il y avait vraiment
une appétence pour venir apporter son
soutien et marquer par un rassemblement
notre appui au peuple marocain mais
aussi vite aussi fort avec autant de
monde s'y attendais pas et vous l'avez
vu beaucoup de nous disent merci d'avoir
organisé ce temps parce que au-delà de
l'humour et du bon moment passé ensemble
c'est une façon d'être solidaire
collectivement sur scène ils sont quatre
à s'être succédé entre humour et
solidarité mais rien Benoît est né à
Casablanca c'est magnifique de pouvoir
aider et faire rire les gens il y a que
du bon dans Ça c'est trop bien j'ai
adoré jouer devant eux ils sont
tellement chaleureux bienveillants et en
plus on sait tous qu'on est là pour une
raison pour cette raison là pour aider
le Maroc donc du coup il y a vraiment
que de la bienveillance un spectacle
caritatif au profit du Secours populaire
le gala lui a permis de récolter plus de
7000 euros le Secours populaire des
Yvelines c'est vu remettre un chèque de
5000 euros de la commune ça va servir à
acheminer et à distribuer des produits
de première nécessité donc là ils ont
déjà commencé sur place à distribuer du
matériel pour que les personnes puissent
faire la cuisine et des panneaux des
panneaux solaires pour pouvoir permettre
de s'éclairer une collecte de produits
de nécessité est aussi en cours à trappe
vêtements chauds tentes couvertures pour
donner un rendez-vous au centre de
loisirs Petit Gibus
[Musique]
envers les autres membres de la
communauté éducative et plus largement
tout personnel de l'éducation nationale
qui oeuvre à la prise en charge de votre
fils et agit au mieux à son égard rendu
public la réponse a été fermement
condamnée par le gouvernement qui a fait
de la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire sa grande cause contactez
l'académie de Versailles pour le moment
pas souhaité s'exprimer pour cette
représentante de parents d'élèves le
manque de considération pose problème de
ne pas avoir pris assez en compte
l'inquiétude de cette famille c'est ça
qui reprochable le contexte la situation
malheureusement ce drame n'avons pas à
jugement apporter sur la situation
cependant le fait que une famille évolue
alerter et voulu protéger son enfant se
soit vu répondre avec aussi peu de
considération et surtout
finalement doivent maintenant
vivre sans leur son enfant ça c'est
inattendable ce n'est pas la première
fois que le rectorat de Versailles se
trouve au centre des critiques en
octobre 2020 à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty avait déjà
mis en lumière des dysfonctionnements de
l'Académie dans une plainte déposée en
2022 par la famille de l'enseignant le
rectorat de Versailles est accusé de ne
pas avoir pris de mesures de protection
malgré les signalements
le roi d'Angleterre est de passage dans
les Yvelines de visite en France du 20
au 22 septembre Charles III rejoindra
Emmanuel Macron au château de Versailles
pour un dîner d'État une forme de clin
d'oeil à la reine Elizabeth II qui avait
déjeuné au même endroit en 1957 150
convives sont attendus dans la galerie
des Glaces le Téléthon c'est le 8 et 9
décembre prochain mais dans les Yvelines
la mobilisation a commencé depuis le 16
septembre Les Clayes-sous-Bois sera la
commune référence du mouvement elle
succède à Mani les hameaux pour
représenter le département activités
sportives et conférence sur les enjeux
du mouvement étaient au programme avec
12000 euros collectés en 2022 la ville
et les bénévoles de l'association de la
lutte contre les maladies génétiques
sont prêts à relever le défi ce dimanche
17 septembre se tenait le World clean
update une journée mondiale du nettoyage
pour prendre conscience de l'impact des
déchets sauvages sur notre environnement
sa poubelle pince et gants étaient les
outils indispensables pour dénicher les
détritus parfois bien dans les buissons
une quinzaine d'habitants ont pris part
au rassemblement dans le quartier de la
mairie de Voisins-le-Bretonneux
c'est un peu triché mais oui il y a
beaucoup de choses avant on faisait ça
aussi dans notre sensibilité et puis
j'adore l'écologie la nature et du coup
je les ai tous forcés et on aime surtout
bien nettoyer la vie pour que la planète
soit en bonne santé en parallèle des
journées du patrimoine en 50 ans en
Yvelines on fêté le vélo samedi dernier
visite du Vélodrome national initiation
au BMX et à la piste de nombreuses
activités étaient proposées même préparé
son propre jus de pomme était possible à
10 mois des épreuves de cyclisme de
Paris 2024 c'est aussi un moyen de
mobiliser les habitants salariés
visiteurs de Saint-Quentin autour d'un
sport fédérateur en sachant que que
Saint-Quentin accueille plusieurs
épreuves olympiques liées au vélo
[Musique]
on commence par du baseball une finale
de première division rajante pour les
Cougars de Montigny-le-Bretonneux il
perdent le titre sur le dernier match
après avoir égalisé à deux victoires
partout sur le terrain de Montpellier il
s'incline finalement dans la dernière
partie sur le score de 8 à 0 c'est la
deuxième finale perdue par les cougars
sur les deux finales disputés
en football enfin une victoire pour le
FC Versailles dans le championnat de
National les Versailles se sont imposés
ce vendredi sur la pelouse de
Châteauroux sur le score de 2 à 0 à
l'occasion de la 6e journée les buts
sont signés Thibault Jacques sur penalty
Chris Kevin Najet après ce résultat les
joueurs de la cité royale pointent à la
13e place du championnat prochain match
à domicile au stade Jean-Bouin de Paris
contre Villefranche Beaujolais toujours
en football ont joué ce week-end le
troisième tour de la Coupe de France
plusieurs équipes divinoises étaient en
lisses les principaux résultats ou ils
s'imposent contre Rueil-Malmaison 3-1
Hardricourt s'incline contre Saint-Cloud
de 1 Chambourcy a perdu sur son terrain
5 1 2 contre Évry Sartrouville gagne
contre Vitry 2-1 et trap c'est
facilement qualifié pour le quatrième
tour contre Dourdan le score 600 ce
quatrième de programmer le 1er octobre
des clubs de National 2 feront leur
entrée à cette occasion en rugby fortune
diverses pour les équipes
internationales installées dans les
Yvelines pendant cette Coupe du monde
les îles Tonga installées à
Croissy-sur-Seine ont perdu face aux
favoris irlandais sur le score de 59 à
16 de leur côté le Pays de Galles qui a
pour quand basse Versailles est imposé à
28 à 8 contre le Portugal
en tennis le tournoi international de la
ville de plaisir c'est terminé ce
dimanche 17 septembre la finale a tenu
toutes ses promesses au bout du suspense
si l'allemand mats Rosen crunch qui
l'emporte face aux Français Antoine Wang
le score 6 3 6 7 6 le tournoi
international de plaisir reviendra
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition on termine par du golf deux
cadors du circuit ont confirmé leur
participation à l'Open de France 2023
l'Américain Billy yorkshell jeune
prodigieux sud-coréen Tom Kim
participeront à la compétition qui se
déroulera du 21 au 24 septembre au Golf
National de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines du
côté des Français livinois Antoine
Rosner sera de la partie
[Musique]
des figurines emblématiques de l'univers
de Star Wars des droïdes et des joueurs
aguerris l'ambiance était galactique
salle Raymond patte notre à Rambouillet
pendant deux jours des compétiteurs se
sont affrontés sur Star Wars légion un
jeu édité par le Guyancourtois asmodé
l'idée c'est que les joueurs vont
s'affronter sur un scénario et sur le
scénario ils vont avoir une mission
réalisée qui peut être qui va être tirée
au hasard par exemple récupérer un otage
au milieu aller récupérer une caisse
pouce chercher des ravitaillements
quelque chose de l'univers de Star Wars
en fait pour l'occasion des joueurs sont
venus des quatre coins de la France mais
aussi de la Belgique et de la Suisse ils
étaient plus de 150 ce qui en a fait le
plus grand tournoi du monde c'est le
plus grand mondial même aux États-Unis
ils ont pas été capables de faire 152
joueurs donc c'est c'est un très très
grand événement français c'est
incroyable qu'on puisse faire ça ici
donc c'est avec des orgas au top
vraiment il y a vraiment rien à dire on
retrouve des copains on est venu à
plusieurs de Saint-Étienne dans une
seule voiture donc on a passé déjà 4 h à
discuter de ça on va repasser 4 heures à
discuter dans la voiture au retour on a
repassé 4 heures au resto hier soir à
parler comme ça c'est vraiment un
week-end un peu hors du temps avec une
ambiance géniale et des belles parties
des belles personnes des belles
figurines voilà c'est super à l'issue de
cette compétition les 8 meilleurs
joueurs se sont qualifiés pour les
championnats du monde qui se tiendront à
Chicago en mars 2024
des conditions plus en adéquation avec
la météo d'un mois de septembre demain
matin le ciel sera couvert dans les
Yvelines c'est à Oudon qui fera le plus
frais compter 12 degrés dans les
secteurs de Versailles Mantes-la-Jolie
il fera 14 degrés dans l'après-midi peu
de changement le thermomètre grimpera 20
degrés au nord-ouest des Yvelines il
fera 19 degrés à Rambouillet et
Versailles et demain mardi 19 septembre
nous fêterons les Émilie tout de suite
l'invité du 7 8
[Musique]
fixez les grands objectifs énergétiques
de la France pour répondre aux défis de
du dérèglement climatique c'est
l'ambition qui est fixée par la future
loi de programmation sur l'énergie et le
climat la ministre de la transition
énergétique Agnès ruacher à missionné 7
groupes de travail qui ont pu rendre il
y a quelques jours une centaine de
conclusions sur le sujet bonjour
Jean-Baptiste vous êtes le maire de
Villepreux également membre du bureau de
l'association des petites villes de
France et vous avez vous copiloter le
groupe de travail numéro 4 auprès du
député des Hauts-de-Seine pierre
Cazeneuve un groupe de travail qui
portait sur la production de chaleur et
les énergies bas carbone donc pour
répondre à de nombreuses questions sur
sur ce sujet d'importance on rappelle
les objectifs fixés c'est de réduire la
consommation d'énergie carbonée de 40%
d'ici à 2040 tout en développant dans le
même temps la consommation d'énergie
cette fois-ci des carbonée on parle d'un
gros défi on parle même du défi du
siècle pour pour ce sujet oui de toute
façon le défi énergétique le défi du
climat on règle générale pour nous doit
être la priorité vous l'avez dit c'est
le défi du siècle je crois qu'il faut
une mobilisation de tous les acteurs les
gouvernements les États les
collectivités les particuliers les
entreprises et on a réussi à démontrer
que c'était possible au moment où le
plan de se briété sobriété énergétique a
été enclenchée puisque grâce aux efforts
de tous nous avons réussi à diminuer de
10% notre consommation d'énergie
maintenant il faut passer de la sobriété
subit à la sobriété choisie l'efficacité
énergétique d'où cette loi qui a pour
objectif de planifier et de programmer
nos objectifs par ressources par énergie
par usage sur les prochaines décennies
et pourtant la rentrée on ne parle pas
de ce sujet on a parlé davantage de
laïcité on parle aussi d'une future loi
sur l'immigration on parle d'emploi on
parle aussi de numérique moins de
transition énergétique est-ce que ça
fait partie des priorités du
gouvernement peut-être qu'en cette
rentrée scolaire c'est le sujet de
l'inflation qui est le plus présent
après je pense qu'il ne faut pas opposer
fin du mois à fin du monde c'est
l'éternel débat non justement les
travaux engagés par la ministre Agnès
manière une archer sur et bien c'est le
groupe de travail et d'ailleurs je salue
la méthode parce que pour la première
fois on a une méthode de co-construction
qui implique des parlementaires certes
mais aussi des élus locaux des
associations d'élus les collectivités
donc les professionnels des filières des
secteurs des syndicats et cela montre
que le gouvernement est pleinement et
bien à la tâche pour
proposer un texte qui devrait arriver
prochainement au Parlement pour
planifier et programmer l'énergie du
pays sur les prochaines années on va
parler dans un instant de vos
principales conclusions je le disais sur
la forme vous avez copiloté ce groupe de
travail avec Pierre Cazeneuve député des
Hauts-de-Seine concrètement c'est un
travail qui a duré 4 mois qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé pendant 4 mois alors ça a
été assez intensif on se connaissait pas
avec Pierre c'est d'ailleurs été une
belle rencontre et on avait une douzaine
de participants dans notre groupe de
travail encore une fois des élus des
responsables et bien de filières etc et
nous avons auditionné plus d'une
trentaine d'acteurs des auditions des
déplacements de terrain aussi notamment
ici dans les Yvelines pour aller voir le
projet de géothermie à auchener au
concours pour aller voir aussi la
station géothermie à Vélizy alors on n'a
pas fait que de la géothermie puisque on
va peut-être le l'évoquer il y a
évidemment plusieurs énergies qui ont
été abordées dans le cadre de notre
groupe de travail mais oui un gros
travail de 4 mois qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de rendre un certain nombre
de pistes de réflexion plutôt que des
conclusions puisque après ce sera à la
ministre de son appareil si elle le
souhaite dans ce qui va être le temps
prochain de l'écriture de la loi dans
vos conclusion il y a notamment l'une
des énergies qui est revenue c'est la
biomasse si vous pouvez juste rappeler
ce comment fonctionne la biomasse et je
crois que c'est un sujet d'ailleurs qui
a suscité pas mal de débats au sein de
votre groupe de travail alors nous on
est parti d'un constat très simple c'est
que aujourd'hui l'usage et l'énergie
électrique l'électricité ne peut suffire
à nous permettre d'être autonome sur le
plan énergétique et puis surtout
d'envisager la programmation d'énergie
pour les décennies à venir donc nous nos
préconisations sont simples c'est
d'accélérer partout c'est possible sur
les énergies renouvelables et sur les
énergies dites à carbone parmi elles la
biomasse le sujet de la biomasse on le
sait c'est que ce n'est pas une énergie
et une ressource extensible à souhait
donc tout l'enjeu et ça a été l'objet
vous l'avez dit de nombreux débats au
sein de notre groupe c'était de pouvoir
quantifier et bien le potentiel que
consiste la biomasse et surtout de
pouvoir hiérarchiser hiérarchiser pardon
et prioriser en fonction des usages nous
ce qu'on attend maintenant de la loi
c'est qu'elle puisse définir sur la
ressource biomasse notamment vers quels
usages en la cible en quelle proportion
et avec des échéances évidemment datées
concrètement la biomasse si on peut
rappeler en quoi ça consiste la biomasse
est évidemment issue au niveau des sols
et notamment au niveau de de de
l'agriculture on a dû auditionné
d'ailleurs France bois et forêt puisque
c'est un acteur très important
concrètement il faut être assez vigilant
puisque l'idée c'est pas de venir porter
atteinte à notre biodiversité et à notre
patrimoine naturel vous voulez aussi
alors sur cette question des énergies la
mise en place d'un plan national de la
géothermie vous avez parlé justement de
la géothermie avec des déplacements à
Vélizy au Chesnay rock en cours
également ça consisterait en quoi ce
plan national alors déjà il faut
rappeler que aujourd'hui
40% 45% de notre consommation finale
énergie c'est la chaleur la chaleur
représente 45% et 24% aujourd'hui de
cette chaleur est perdue et non
renouvelable donc il faut maintenant
qu'on avance vers d'autres modèles de
production la géothermie est en est une
solution on a fait un certain nombre de
déplacements pour pouvoir voir
concrètement comment les collectivités
s'emparer du sujet il y a de beaux
projets qui ont pu voir le jour ou qui
vont voir le jour dans les Yvelines et
effectivement nous faisons cette
proposition d'un plan de
géoterminational concrètement ce que ça
veut dire c'est donner la possibilité
aux collectivités au territoire de
connaître l'état actuel de leur sous-sol
et de savoir si au niveau des gisements
un niveau des ressources et bien du du
sous-sol il y a des potentiels pour
pouvoir développer des projets
géothermiques en cette rentrée on parle
aussi notamment des prix des carburants
en matière de carburant très
spécifiquement quelles ont été vos
conclusions sur le sujet il va falloir
qu'on avance et qu'on accélère sur le
stockage et la logistique des
biocarburants on le voit aussi quand on
parle du gaz le sujet du gaz notamment
sur les réseaux c'est qu'il va falloir
que les réseaux demain puissent être
compatibles pour éventuellement avoir
d'autres types de gaz et d'autres types
évidemment et bien de ressources
maintenant il va falloir programmer les
choses il va falloir aussi que les
différents acteurs mettent la main à la
pâte puisque tout ça c'était aussi
l'objet du groupe de travail 7 il y a un
enjeu financier budgétaire il y aura des
arbitrages qui devront être faits plus
tard entre la ministre et son homologue
à Bercy Bruno Le Maire donc oui en tout
cas nous notre notre sujet est de dire
le nucléaire est une une mode de
production d'énergie dont nous pouvons
nous passer pour le moment notamment sur
la partie électricité maintenant il faut
développer toutes les énergies
renouvelables partout c'est possible en
ayant à l'esprit comme on l'a dit pour
la biomasse que certaines ne sont pas
extensibles à souhait et une autre des
conclusions c'est de renforcer le rôle
de l'ADEME alors on le rappelle l'ADEME
c'est une c'est l'agence du
développement durable on peut la
présenter
qu'est-ce que ça impliquerait aussi de
renforcer le rôle de la dame et pourquoi
vouloir renforcer son rôle alors nous
déjà on souhaiterait que dans un temps
très prochain son budget annuel soit
porté à un milliard avant d'atteindre
les 2,4 milliards d'ici 2030 l'ADEME on
a besoin de la DM comme agence pilote
comme agence coordinatrice on va dire
d'un certain nombre de thématiques liées
à l'énergie c'est d'ailleurs la
proposition que nous ont pour la
biomasse que l'ADEME soit cette fameuse
agence qui puisse nous dire comment on
peut utiliser cette énergie cette
ressource en quelle proportion et il est
vrai aujourd'hui que l'ADEME pour nous
nous paraît être l'acteur le plus
important ça ça fait partie des
propositions assez innovantes que nous
faisons en espérant qu'elle soit suivie
maintenant du coup vient le temps pour
la ministre de la transition énergétique
de recueillir toutes ces conclusions
très concrètement pour les propositions
que vous avez pu faire avec votre groupe
de travail vous allez bon espoir qui est
soit retenue dans les laboration de la
future loi oui alors là on est vraiment
dans la phase préparatoire c'est-à-dire
que d'ailleurs encore une fois je salue
cette démarche de co-construction on a
fait un certain nombre de propositions
elles sont sur la table évidemment que
si nous avons eu la possibilité de les
présenter c'est que la ministre est
plutôt en soutien aux propositions que
nous avons formulées maintenant on sait
comment ça se passe le texte une fois
qui sera écrit va devoir aller au
Parlement à l'Assemblée au Sénat il va y
avoir la navette il va y avoir le
travail des commissions il y aura
peut-être des amendements moi j'espère
surtout que comme les deux textes
précédents qui ont touché l'énergie les
énergies renouvelables et la création de
PR notamment pour le pour le nucléaire
évidemment soit adopté j'espère que ce
ne sera pas un sujet qui sera utilisé à
des fins politiques aux politiciennes
par les oppositions
qu'on arrivera à se retrouver autour
d'une ambition commune puisqu'on l'a dit
en début d'entretien c'est le défi du
siècle et donc pouvoir programmer
planifier ce sont pas des gros mots au
contraire c'est un besoin vital pour
avoir une trajectoire très claire et
très précise pour la France sur le
calendrier ça paraît presque impossible
que ce texte arrive au Parlement d'ici
la fin de l'année du coup c'est quoi
l'objectif c'est 2024 ça je sais pas il
faudra voir avec les présidents des
chambres il y a LeBron Pivet et Gérard
Larcher bon en plus il y a un contexte
d'élection sénatoriale qui fait que il y
a un certain nombre de textes qui vont
peut-être être inscrits à l'ordre du
jour des chambres un peu plus tard en
tout cas si ce n'est pas fait avant la
fin 2023 ce sera fait début d'année 2024
mais moi j'ai bon espoir et puis on a la
chance d'avoir une ministre sur ce sujet
qui arrive aussi à faire consensus et à
trouver les arguments qui permettent
avec l'ensemble des acteurs autour de la
table d'avancer sur ce sujet important
un dernier mot un bilan plus personnel
sur ces quatre mois dans ce groupe de
travail alors vous avez participé on le
rappelle en tant que mère d'une commune
Villepreux mais aussi en tant que membre
du bureau de l'association des petites
villes de France passionnant très
stimulant sur le point sur le plan
intellectuel moi ce sont des sujets
évidemment qui me passionnent puisque à
Villepreux tout le projet de mandat a
été bâti autour des 17 objectifs de
développement durable il y a de
l'efficacité énergétique notamment sur
notre programme de rénovation du bâtis
scolaire je vais pas rentrer sur Tous
les programmes mais en tout cas ce sont
des thématiques pour moi qui sont très
importantes je souhaite porter des
politiques publiques justement qui
permettent de les accompagner ça a été
un gros travail là je vais dire que une
petite partie de mon agenda sur les
toutes prochaines semaines va un petit
peu s'alléger parce qu'on a beaucoup
travaillé avec Pierre et les différents
membres du groupe de travail mais je
crois que c'était important de porter la
parole des territoires et je voudrais
peut-être conclure là dessus les
territoires aujourd'hui vont être
finalement les lieux où ces projets
d'énergie et d'énergie renouvelables
notamment vont voir le jour ça peut être
décidé au niveau de l'État mais c'est
bien des solutions concrètes sur les
territoires et bien qui vont s'engager
et donc ça ça ne pouvait pas se faire
sans les élus locaux et c'est la raison
pour laquelle avec petite ville de
France on a répondu présent à l'appel de
la ministre pour participer à ces
travaux merci Jean-Baptiste amonique
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ici
devant la mairie de Villepreux vous
l'aurez sans doute reconnu voilà c'est
la fin du 7 8 merci de nous avoir suivis
très belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]